bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação
da IBM Quantum. Esta é a nona aula da série e é a primeira aula da terceira unidade, que trata da formulação geral
da informação quântica. Até agora, usamos a formulação simplificada da
informação quântica, onde os estados quânticos são representados por vetores complexos com norma euclidiana igual a
um. Em contraste, na formulação geral da informação quântica, os estados quânticos são representados por
matrizes de um certo tipo conhecidas como matrizes de densidade. Esta primeira aula da unidade foca em matrizes de densidade especificamente
e vamos entender o que são e como funcionam ao longo da aula. As matrizes de densidade são extremamente
úteis e oferecem diversas vantagens que vamos discutir. Elas nos permitem representar uma
classe mais ampla de estados do que os vetores de estado quântico conseguem, incluindo estados de sistemas afetados por ruído, por exemplo, bem como seleções aleatórias
de estados quânticos. Também vamos dar uma olhada na esfera de Bloch, que nos oferece uma forma geométrica muito elegante
e simples de pensar sobre os estados de qubit, e vamos ver como ela se conecta com as matrizes de densidade de uma
maneira bastante notável, através das matrizes de Pauli. Por fim, vamos discutir as matrizes de densidade no contexto de múltiplos
sistemas e, em particular, vamos ver como elas nos permitem descrever estados quânticos de sistemas vistos de forma isolada, mesmo quando
estão correlacionados com outros sistemas. E isso inclui a possibilidade de que estejam entrelaçados com outros sistemas. Esta é uma coisa importante de conseguir
fazer e não é facilmente feita dentro da formulação simplificada da informação quântica. Aqui está uma visão geral da
aula. Vamos começar com os fundamentos das matrizes de densidade, incluindo definições relevantes e alguns exemplos, e vamos
também discutir como elas se conectam aos vetores de estado quântico. Em seguida, vamos falar sobre combinações convexas de matrizes de densidade ou, em
outras palavras, o que acontece quando calculamos médias ponderadas de matrizes de densidade. Vamos começar com um
exemplo específico do chamado estado completamente misto. Vamos ver como os estados probabilísticos clássicos podem ser vistos como
casos especiais de matrizes de densidade e vamos discutir como o teorema espectral da álgebra linear entra em cena neste
contexto. A terceira parte da aula é sobre a esfera de Bloch, que fornece uma forma geométrica de visualizar os estados de
cubits individuais, como mencionei no início da aula. E na quarta parte da aula vamos falar sobre como as matrizes de densidade funcionam para múltiplos
sistemas. Vamos discutir estados produto e estados correlacionados de diferentes tipos, incluindo estados entrelaçados, bem como
a noção de estado reduzido, que é uma descrição em termos de matriz de densidade do estado de uma parte isolada de um sistema composto
que pode ser calculada usando uma operação conhecida como traço parcial. Antes de chegarmos ao conteúdo técnico da aula em si, é
oportuno dedicar alguns momentos para motivar o uso das matrizes de densidade. Usando a formulação simplificada
da informação quântica, que não envolve matrizes de densidade, somos capazes de descrever algoritmos quânticos como o
algoritmo de fatoração de Shor, por exemplo, sem nenhuma dificuldade. Então por que devemos nos preocupar com as matrizes de densidade
ou com essa formulação geral da informação quântica? Bem, há múltiplas razões. Em primeiro lugar, as matrizes de densidade
representam uma classe mais ampla de estados quânticos do que os vetores de estado quântico, incluindo estados quânticos onde temos incerteza ou
aleatoriedade. Isso é importante quando queremos modelar os efeitos do ruído em computações quânticas, por
exemplo. Em segundo lugar, usando matrizes de densidade podemos descrever estados quânticos de partes isoladas de sistemas compostos, como
os estados de sistemas que estão entrelaçados com outros sistemas que talvez momentaneamente escolhamos ignorar. Como mencionei no início da
aula, isso não é facilmente ou naturalmente feito dentro da formulação simplificada da informação
quântica. Uma terceira razão é que quando usamos matrizes de densidade a informação clássica emerge de fato como um
caso especial. Então, em vez de termos o que é essencialmente uma analogia entre estados probabilísticos e operações, por
um lado, e vetores de estado quântico e operações unitárias, por outro lado, temos a informação quântica e clássica
sendo descritas juntas dentro de um único framework matemático, o que é praticamente essencial para o estudo matemático
da informação quântica. Então, se tu és sério sobre entender a informação quântica num nível matemático, é altamente
recomendado que aprendas sobre matrizes de densidade. Vamos começar com a definição de matrizes de
densidade. Para fins da definição, suponha que X é um sistema e sigma é seu conjunto de estados clássicos. E lembre que
quando usamos essa terminologia, nossa suposição é que Sigma é finito e não vazio e, como sempre, poderíamos escolher
nomes diferentes se quiséssemos. Uma matriz de densidade que descreve um estado do sistema X é uma matriz com
entradas de números complexos cujas linhas e colunas foram colocadas em correspondência com seu conjunto de estados clássicos e, para ser claro,
é a mesma correspondência para as linhas e as colunas simultaneamente. Isso significa que as matrizes de
densidade são sempre matrizes quadradas. E além de serem quadradas, há algumas condições que precisam ser
satisfeitas e vamos chegar a elas em breve. As pessoas geralmente usam certas letras gregas minúsculas para nomear
matrizes de densidade. Rho é muitas vezes a primeira escolha e outras escolhas comuns incluem sigma minúsculo e tau, que são mostrados na
tela. Isso é apenas uma convenção mas, como de costume, esse tipo de convenção é útil porque torna as coisas mais
facilmente reconhecíveis. E agora vamos falar sobre as condições ou os requisitos que as matrizes de densidade devem satisfazer para serem
matrizes de densidade válidas. Há duas delas e o que vou fazer é primeiro apenas listá-las
e depois vou discutir em mais detalhes o que elas significam. A primeira condição é que as matrizes de
densidade devem ter traço unitário, ou em outras palavras, traço igual a um. E a segunda condição é que
as matrizes de densidade devem ser positivas semidefinidas. E em ambos os casos temos formas simbólicas concisas de expressar
essas duas condições que aparecem na tela. Agora deixa eu discutir as duas condições em mais detalhes.
A primeira condição se refere ao traço, que é uma função muito importante definida para todas as matrizes quadradas
e é simplesmente a soma das entradas diagonais. E aqui está uma equação que expressa isso
explicitamente. Agora há bastante coisa a ser dita sobre o traço e por que ele é importante, mas por ora vamos apenas observar
uma propriedade muito básica dele, que é ser uma função linear. Outras propriedades do traço surgirão e vamos discuti-las conforme
necessário. Mas para manter nosso foco nas matrizes de densidade, vamos passar para o segundo requisito. E esse requisito é que
as matrizes de densidade são positivas semidefinidas. Esse também é um conceito importante que surge em muitos contextos em
física, química, otimização, aprendizado de máquina e outras áreas. E pode ser expressa de várias formas diferentes, mas
equivalentes. Uma forma de expressar isso é dizer que uma matriz rho é positiva semidefinida se existe uma matriz M
tal que rho é igual a M dagger vezes M. E acontece que não importa se exigimos que M em si seja uma
matriz quadrada ou se abrimos mão dessa restrição. Outra forma de expressar o que significa uma matriz rho ser positiva
semidefinida é dizer que rho é hermitiana, o que significa que ela é igual à sua própria transposta conjugada, e todos os seus
autovalores são números reais não negativos. Em geral, as matrizes hermitianas só podem
ter autovalores reais, mas eles podem ser negativos. Mas se incluirmos a restrição adicional de que nenhum dos
autovalores pode ser negativo, obtemos as matrizes positivas semidefinidas. E, aliás, se você tiver
uma matriz e quiser saber se ela é positiva semidefinida, pode determinar isso usando essa caracterização. É bastante fácil
verificar se uma matriz é hermitiana, isso é algo que pode ser visto a olho nu. É mais difícil calcular
os autovalores, mas isso não é tão difícil de fazer com um computador porque existem algoritmos muito eficientes para isso.
E a última caracterização que vou mencionar, embora existam outras, é que para todo vetor coluna s com
um número de entradas que concorda com o número de linhas e o número de colunas de rho, a inequação mostrada na
tela é verdadeira. Em palavras, bra s vezes rho vezes ket s deve ser um número real
não negativo. Não é óbvio, aliás, que essas caracterizações são todas equivalentes, mas são. E deixa eu notar explicitamente que a
notação que usamos comumente para indicar que uma matriz rho é positiva semidefinida parece que rho é maior
ou igual a zero, mas isso é apenas uma notação abreviada e não significa literalmente que rho é maior que
ou igual a zero. Rho é uma matriz, então isso não faria sentido. E também não significa
que cada uma das entradas de rho é maior ou igual a zero. Em particular, há matrizes
positivas semidefinidas cujas entradas não são todas não negativas, e há matrizes cujas entradas são todas não
negativas mas que não são positivas semidefinidas. A ideia por trás da notação é que as matrizes positivas semidefinidas
são como análogos matriciais dos números reais não negativos, mas isso é apenas notação e o que significa é
precisamente o que já discutimos. Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos, começando com um exemplo de uma
matriz positiva semidefinida. Na verdade, é bem fácil gerar aleatoriamente um exemplo de uma
matriz positiva semidefinida simplesmente escolhendo uma matriz M arbitrariamente e então calculando M dagger vezes
M. Por exemplo, aqui está uma matriz M que não é particularmente especial e, de fato,
eu gerei essa matriz aleatoriamente, escolhendo de forma independente as partes real e imaginária das entradas como inteiros entre menos 9 e positivo
9. Então qualquer padrão ou estrutura aqui é puramente coincidência. Multiplicando a
transposta conjugada de M por M, obtemos essa matriz aqui, que é portanto positiva
semidefinida. Claro que há um limite para o quanto de conhecimento podemos ganhar de um exemplo aleatório, mas ele exibe algumas
características que são comuns às matrizes positivas semidefinidas em geral. Em particular, você vai notar
que as entradas diagonais, ou seja, as que estão ao longo da linha do canto superior esquerdo ao inferior direito, são todas números reais não negativos
e, além disso, as entradas fora da diagonal não são muito grandes em comparação com as entradas diagonais correspondentes,
ou seja, a que está na mesma linha e a que está na mesma coluna de qualquer entrada fora da diagonal que estejamos analisando.
Mas há mais nessa história, e é importante reconhecer que ser positiva semidefinida é uma
propriedade de uma matriz como um todo e não apenas uma condição sobre entradas individuais. Então esse é um exemplo de uma
matriz positiva semidefinida e você pode facilmente gerar outros exemplos por uma
metodologia similar. Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos de matrizes de densidade onde, além da condição de positiva semidefinida, também temos que o traço é
igual a um. Aqui estão alguns exemplos de matrizes de densidade 2x2. O traço é igual a
um em todos os quatro casos e podemos também ver que essas são matrizes hermitianas. Então, usando a segunda caracterização das
matrizes positivas semidefinidas de antes, tudo o que resta é verificar que os autovalores são todos não negativos.
Vou deixar isso para você verificar se quiser. Para matrizes 2x2 não é muito difícil calcular os autovalores à mão,
mas você também pode simplesmente pedir a um computador para fazer isso. Por exemplo, você pode usar a função eigvals no pacote de álgebra linear
para Python. Também podemos obter uma matriz de densidade simplesmente pegando qualquer
matriz positiva semidefinida não nula e dividindo pelo seu traço. Por exemplo, aqui está a matriz de densidade que obtemos
dividindo o exemplo que vimos há pouco pelo seu traço. Dividir pelo traço assim
sempre preservará a propriedade de positiva semidefinida e certamente obteremos uma matriz com traço igual a um em virtude do fato de que
o traço é uma função linear. Essa é apenas uma pequena coleção de exemplos e veremos mais conforme a
aula continua. A seguir, vamos dedicar alguns momentos para discutir a interpretação ou
significado intuitivo das matrizes de densidade. A primeira coisa a reconhecer é que pode parecer um pouco incomum
estar representando o estado de um sistema com uma matriz em vez de um vetor. Em contraste, na formulação simplificada
da informação quântica usamos vetores para representar estados, enquanto matrizes, especificamente matrizes unitárias,
representam ações ou operações. É assim que a matemática funciona e, embora você possa
sempre pensar em matrizes como descrevendo mapeamentos lineares, geralmente não associamos um significado intuitivo direto
ao mapeamento linear associado a uma dada matriz de densidade. Dito isso, o fato de que
as matrizes de densidade são de fato matrizes acaba sendo um aspecto criticamente importante delas e vamos ver
isso conforme avançamos. Mas para mencionar brevemente apenas um exemplo por ora, os autovalores de uma dada matriz de densidade
acabam sendo muito importantes porque descrevem quanta aleatoriedade ou incerteza é inerente ao estado
que essa matriz de densidade descreve. Uma forma diferente de pensar sobre as matrizes de densidade num nível intuitivo
foca nas entradas dessas matrizes. Lembre que as linhas e colunas das matrizes de densidade são colocadas
em correspondência com os estados clássicos de qualquer sistema sobre o qual estamos falando. Então para cada entrada temos um
estado clássico correspondente à linha dessa entrada e um estado clássico correspondente à coluna dessa
entrada. Para as entradas diagonais, esses dois estados clássicos são o mesmo estado, e é por isso que as entradas diagonais são
especiais. E uma forma de interpretar as entradas diagonais é que elas são probabilidades, e especificamente são
as probabilidades de que o estado clássico correspondente apareceria se realizássemos uma medição na base padrão
no sistema cujo estado quântico estamos descrevendo. Para as entradas fora da diagonal, por outro lado, temos um estado clássico correspondente à linha
dessa entrada e um estado clássico diferente correspondente à coluna dessa entrada. E de forma muito informal,
essas entradas descrevem o grau em que esses dois estados clássicos estão em superposição quântica, bem como a
fase relativa entre eles. Isso pode fazer mais sentido conforme a aula avançar e olharmos mais
de perto para alguns exemplos específicos. E os detalhes podem não estar claros neste ponto, mas por favor não deixe isso te incomodar.
Isso é bastante informal e é apenas uma ideia intuitiva para manter na parte de trás da
mente. A seguir, vamos dar uma olhada na conexão entre as matrizes de densidade e os vetores de estado quântico, que são vetores coluna
com norma euclidiana igual a um. Só para lembrar a definição matemática, suponha que temos um
vetor de estado quântico s que representa o estado de algum sistema específico. A matriz de densidade que representa o mesmo
estado quântico é dada por ket psi vezes bra psi, como mostrado aqui na tela. Para ser claro sobre isso, os índices de psi
correspondem de alguma forma aos estados clássicos de qualquer sistema sobre o qual estamos falando, e isso será precisamente a mesma correspondência que temos entre
as linhas e colunas de nossa matriz de densidade e os estados clássicos do sistema. Se imaginarmos que há n
estados clássicos do sistema e pensarmos sobre vetores coluna e linha como matrizes, então ket é uma matriz N por 1
e bra é uma matriz 1 por n. Então quando realizamos a multiplicação obtemos uma matriz N por N.
Isso sempre será uma matriz positiva semidefinida só pela sua forma, e também terá traço igual
a um em virtude do fato de que s é um vetor unitário, e veremos isso com mais detalhes
em breve. Os estados quânticos que são representados por matrizes de densidade desta forma são chamados de estados
puros. Aqui estão alguns exemplos. Primeiro, vamos considerar esse estado
aqui, que é parecido com um estado mais, exceto que a entrada correspondente ao estado clássico um é
imaginária. Se calcularmos a transposta conjugada, vamos pegar um sinal de menos porque o conjugado complexo de i é
menos i. E se fizermos a multiplicação, obteremos a matriz que está mostrada aqui na tela. É hermitiana como podemos
ver imediatamente só de olhar para ela e por acaso tem um autovalor igual a um e um autovalor igual a
zero. Então é positiva semidefinida e seu traço é igual a um, então é de fato uma matriz de densidade como
esperado. Podemos calcular as matrizes de densidade correspondentes às bases padrão e à base mais-menos de forma similar, e essas matrizes de densidade
são mostradas aqui. E aqui está mais um exemplo de um vetor de estado quântico. Ele apareceu
lá atrás na primeira aula da série. E se calcularmos a transposta conjugada e depois multiplicarmos,
obteremos a matriz de densidade que está mostrada aqui. Mais uma vez, é hermitiana e tem
traço igual a um. E se você calcular os autovalores, vai descobrir que novamente tem um autovalor igual a um e um
autovalor igual a zero. E, aliás, essa é uma característica comum de todos os estados puros. Eles sempre têm um autovalor
igual a um e os demais autovalores são todos zero. Em geral, para um vetor de estado quântico completamente arbitrário
s com qualquer número de entradas, se multiplicarmos ket por bra, obteremos uma
matriz de densidade que parece com esta. Note em particular que as entradas diagonais são sempre uma das
entradas de s multiplicada pelo seu próprio conjugado complexo, que também podemos expressar como o valor absoluto ao quadrado dessa entrada. E isso é
uma forma de ver que o traço será sempre igual a um. Também é consistente com o comentário que fiz anteriormente na aula sobre as
entradas diagonais de uma matriz de densidade nos dizendo quais seriam as probabilidades de ver cada possível estado clássico
se realizássemos uma medição na base padrão. E um comentário final:
não há nenhum problema com fases globais para as matrizes de densidade. Dois estados quânticos são idênticos se e somente se suas matrizes de
densidade são iguais. Em particular, suponha que temos dois vetores de estado quântico s e fi que
são equivalentes até uma fase global, o que significa que podemos expressar um deles, fi, digamos, como o outro vezes
algum número complexo no círculo unitário. Se calcularmos a representação em matriz de densidade de fi, então o que
vamos encontrar é que o fator de fase global é multiplicado pelo seu próprio conjugado complexo e isso nos dá um. Então ele
efetivamente desaparece e ficamos exatamente com a mesma matriz de densidade que obtemos de s. Então isso é uma espécie de
bônus extra. E de forma mais geral, não há nenhum problema com equivalência até fases globais quando estamos
trabalhando com matrizes de densidade. Isso é basicamente uma degenerescência que existe quando usamos vetores de estado quântico em vez
de matrizes de densidade para representar estados quânticos. As matrizes de densidade possuem uma propriedade chave, que é que as combinações convexas
de matrizes de densidade representam seleções probabilísticas ou aleatórias de estados
quânticos. Outra forma de dizer isso é que as matrizes de densidade podem ser calculadas em médias de forma significativa, o que é
algo que não podemos fazer com vetores de estado quântico. Para explicar isso em mais detalhes, vamos começar com a situação em que
temos duas matrizes de densidade rho e sigma que representam estados quânticos de algum sistema. Vamos imaginar que o
sistema é preparado no estado rho com probabilidade p, para alguma escolha de p entre zero e um. Do contrário, o
sistema é preparado no estado sigma. Por exemplo, talvez p seja 1/2. Então
podemos imaginar que alguém joga uma moeda justa e se der cara ela realiza algum processo que deixa o sistema no
estado rho e, caso contrário, se a moeda der coroa, ela realiza um processo diferente que deixa o sistema no
estado sigma. A questão agora é qual é o estado do sistema. E para ser claro,
estamos interessados no estado do sistema de forma isolada, desconsiderando qualquer outra informação que possa existir sobre
qual preparação foi realizada. Por exemplo, imagine que não temos acesso à moeda ou à
memória de quem realizou a preparação do estado. E a resposta para essa pergunta é que é simplesmente a média ponderada das duas matrizes de
densidade, p vezes rho mais 1 menos p vezes sigma. Isso, aliás, é completamente
análogo ao que teríamos se rho e sigma não fossem matrizes de densidade mas sim vetores de probabilidade
representando estados probabilísticos. Então isso não é algo chocante ou misterioso, mas sim algo
que talvez seja familiar da teoria de probabilidade. Fazemos esse tipo de média o tempo todo quando estamos calculando probabilidades e pensando
sobre seleções aleatórias clássicas. E o ponto é que isso também funciona para as matrizes de densidade. Mas note que não
funciona para vetores de estado quântico, ou seja, você geralmente não pode calcular a média de dois vetores de estado
quântico assim e esperar obter um vetor de estado quântico válido. E se tentar, geralmente obterá um vetor que
não tem norma euclidiana igual a um. Com matrizes de densidade, no entanto, médias ponderadas assim sempre
serão matrizes de densidade válidas. E mais importante, a matriz de densidade que você obtém representará essa seleção aleatória de
forma significativa. Isso se generaliza para seleções aleatórias onde há mais de duas
alternativas. Em particular, se tivermos M matrizes de densidade possíveis e um vetor de probabilidade com M entradas, um
para cada matriz de densidade, e um sistema for preparado em cada estado possível com a probabilidade correspondente,
então a média ponderada dessas matrizes de densidade descreve o estado resultante do sistema. E, aliás, quando
nos referimos a uma combinação convexa de matrizes de densidade, é isso que queremos dizer. Uma combinação convexa é simplesmente uma combinação linear
onde os coeficientes formam um vetor de probabilidade. Isso sempre será uma matriz de
densidade. E uma forma simples e concisa de dizer isso em termos matemáticos é que o conjunto de todas as matrizes de densidade
correspondentes a um dado sistema é um conjunto convexo. Então, se tivermos, digamos, m vetores de estado quântico
psi 0 a psi M menos um, juntamente com probabilidades p 0 a p m menos um que coletivamente formam um
vetor de probabilidade, e um sistema é preparado no estado s k com probabilidade pk para cada k, então o
estado resultante do sistema é descrito pela matriz de densidade que está mostrada aqui na tela. Em particular, não estamos calculando a média
dos próprios vetores de estado quântico, mas sim calculando a média das matrizes de densidade
correspondentes. Em geral, um estado assim não terá representação como um único vetor de estado
quântico, a menos que algo trivial esteja acontecendo, como todos os vetores de estado quântico serem equivalentes até uma fase global, ou todos, exceto um, dos
probabilidades serem zero. Não obteremos um estado quântico puro de tal processo. Em vez disso, obteremos o que é chamado de
estado quântico misto, onde há alguma incerteza inerente envolvida. Vamos dar uma olhada em um
exemplo simples. Suponha que temos um qubit e com probabilidade 1/2 o qubit é preparado no estado zero e, caso contrário,
é preparado no estado mais. Aqui está a matriz de densidade que obtemos pela média como descrevi.
Calculamos as matrizes de densidade correspondentes aos dois estados possíveis, multiplicamos pelas probabilidades correspondentes e somamos os
resultados. O que obtemos é de fato uma matriz de densidade. É hermitiana, seu traço é igual a um
e se você calcular os autovalores desta matriz vai obter dois números reais positivos. E por acaso são dois números que provavelmente já devem ser
familiares para você agora: cosseno ao quadrado de pi sobre 8 e seno ao quadrado de pi sobre 8, ou cerca de 0,85 e
0,15. Não existe representação por um único vetor de estado quântico para esse estado. Não é um estado puro. A seguir, vamos dar uma olhada em uma
matriz de densidade específica que representa um estado quântico de um único qubit, conhecido como estado completamente
misto. Esse estado surge com frequência, então é bom ter um nome para ele, e também é um bom exemplo porque
ilustra uma característica importante das matrizes de densidade. Há de fato um estado completamente misto definido de forma análoga para qualquer
sistema, mas por ora vamos focar nesse estado para um único qubit, só para manter as coisas
simples. Suponha que definimos aleatoriamente o estado de um qubit como sendo o estado zero ou o estado um, cada um com
probabilidade igual a 1/2, como um bit aleatório uniforme. Podemos calcular a representação em matriz de densidade deste
estado da forma usual. Tomamos a média das duas representações em matriz de densidade dos estados. Aqui está como
isso fica em forma matricial. E o que obtemos é a matriz identidade dividida por
dois. Esse estado é conhecido como estado completamente misto e basicamente representa completa ou máxima
incerteza sobre um qubit, assim como um vetor de probabilidade uniforme representa incerteza máxima no
cenário probabilístico clássico. Em geral, para um sistema arbitrário, o estado completamente misto é o
estado que obtemos escolhendo uniformemente um estado da base padrão, e a representação em matriz de densidade será a
matriz identidade dividida pela dimensão, ou equivalentemente, o número de estados clássicos desse
sistema. A princípio, isso é apenas terminologia, mas se mudarmos um pouco a configuração, veremos uma característica importante das
matrizes de densidade. Em particular, vamos supor que mudamos o procedimento e, em
vez dos estados da base padrão zero e um, substituímos pelos estados mais e menos. Desta vez, começamos com a
expressão que está mostrada na tela, mas se passarmos pela aritmética, obtemos exatamente a mesma
matriz de densidade. É a matriz identidade dividida por dois, então é o mesmo estado de antes: o
estado completamente misto. Isso, como dizem, é uma característica e não um bug. Os dois procedimentos são de fato
diferentes, mas se tudo o que você tem é o qubit resultante, não há forma física possível de distingui-los,
nem mesmo em sentido estatístico. Por exemplo, se você realizasse uma medição na base padrão neste qubit
após o primeiro procedimento ter sido realizado, obviamente obteria o resultado zero com probabilidade 1/2 e o resultado um com probabilidade 1/2. Mas também obteria
exatamente as mesmas probabilidades de resultados para o segundo procedimento. E o mesmo vale para qualquer outro teste que você possa
elaborar, supondo que você esteja testando apenas o qubit em si. Em geral, as matrizes de densidade não descrevem como um sistema foi
preparado. Elas apenas dizem o que acontecerá se você fizer coisas nesse sistema daqui para frente, seja realizando
operações ou medições. E de fato as matrizes de densidade são perfeitas nisso.
Se duas alternativas diferentes resultam na mesma matriz de densidade, elas não podem ser discriminadas nem
estatisticamente. Mas se as duas matrizes de densidade são diferentes, haverá alguma forma de discriminá-las, não
necessariamente definitivamente, mas em sentido estatístico. Quando usamos a formulação geral da informação
quântica, a informação clássica emerge essencialmente como um caso especial. E agora vou explicar como isso
funciona. Especificamente, veremos como os estados probabilísticos podem ser representados por matrizes de
densidade. Vamos começar com os estados clássicos, começando com um
exemplo simples. Aqui estão as representações em matriz de densidade dos estados zero e um da base padrão de um
qubit. Associamos esses estados aos estados clássicos 0 e 1. Então podemos pensar nessas matrizes de densidade como
representando esses estados. Isso é muito simples. E podemos facilmente generalizar o
exemplo. Se tivermos um sistema cujo conjunto de estados clássicos é Sigma, então o estado clássico a é representado por, ou
está associado à, matriz de densidade ket a bra a. Essa matriz tem um único um na
entrada diagonal cuja linha e coluna correspondem ao estado clássico a, e cada outra entrada é
zero. Os estados probabilísticos são representados por combinações convexas de matrizes desta forma, o que é natural
dado o que sabemos sobre as matrizes de densidade e como elas funcionam. Especificamente, que as combinações convexas de matrizes de densidade representam seleções aleatórias ou
probabilísticas de estados quânticos. Por exemplo, vamos supor que
temos um sistema X cujo conjunto de estados clássicos inclui os inteiros de 0 a n menos um, para algum inteiro positivo n. Claro que
há pouca ou nenhuma generalidade perdida ao supor que nosso conjunto de estados clássicos tem essa forma. Se tivéssemos um
conjunto de estados clássicos diferente, poderíamos simplesmente renomear os estados clássicos desta forma. E é geralmente bem conveniente fazer a suposição de que nossos
conjuntos de estados clássicos parecem assim, em grande parte porque isso torna mais fácil escrever coisas explicitamente em termos de
vetores e matrizes. Supondo que temos um estado probabilístico do sistema X
representado por um vetor de probabilidade da forma habitual, podemos associar esse estado probabilístico a uma matriz de
densidade como mostrado na tela. Tomamos a média ponderada das matrizes de densidade correspondentes
aos diferentes estados clássicos. E o que obtemos é uma matriz de densidade diagonal. Em particular, vemos as probabilidades
ao longo da diagonal dessa matriz, e cada outra entrada é igual a zero. Claro que isso é uma matriz de densidade.
Esperamos que isso seja verdade, mas também podemos raciocinar diretamente. É uma matriz hermitiana; seu traço
é igual a um porque as probabilidades somam um. E no caso de uma matriz diagonal, os autovalores são as entradas diagonais
e são todos não negativos porque são probabilidades. Note também que toda
matriz de densidade diagonal, ou seja, uma cujas entradas fora da diagonal são todas zero, deve ter essa aparência. Então, em resumo,
os estados probabilísticos podem ser associados a matrizes de densidade diagonais. Note, aliás, que isso é consistente com a
interpretação informal das entradas das matrizes de densidade que mencionei no início da aula. Em particular, nada está em
superposição quântica aqui. É basicamente apenas aleatoriedade clássica. E correspondentemente, todas as entradas fora da diagonal
são zero. Anteriormente nesta série, discutimos o teorema espectral, e fizemos isso
especificamente para matrizes unitárias no contexto de estimação de fase. O teorema espectral é mais
geral do que isso, no entanto, o que significa que nos diz algo sobre uma classe mais ampla de matrizes do que apenas matrizes unitárias.
Em particular, aplica-se a uma classe de matrizes chamadas matrizes normais, que incluem todas as matrizes hermitianas, bem como
as matrizes unitárias. O que vamos fazer agora é dar uma olhada em uma declaração diferente deste teorema, desta vez focando apenas nas
matrizes positivas semidefinidas, e então veremos que ele nos diz algo muito interessante e criticamente importante sobre as matrizes de
densidade. Suponha que p é qualquer matriz positiva semidefinida, de modo que isso inclui qualquer matriz de densidade, bem como qualquer
matriz positiva semidefinida que não tenha traço igual a um. p é positiva semidefinida, então ela tem que
ser quadrada, ou em outras palavras, N por N para alguma escolha de N. E precisaremos nos referir a esse número n, então seja N
escolhido apropriadamente, ou outra forma de dizer tudo isso é: suponha que p é N por N. O que o teorema nos diz neste caso é que
deve existir uma base ortonormal de vetores que nomearemos s0 a s N menos um, juntamente com números reais não negativos
Lambda 0 a Lambda N menos um, tais que P pode ser expresso como mostrado
aqui na tela. Em palavras, se multiplicarmos cada Lambda k por ket k vezes bra psi k e depois
somarmos sobre todos os k de 0 a n menos um, obteremos P. Isso é chamado de decomposição
espectral de P. Cada Lambda k é necessariamente um autovalor de p e cada psi é um autovetor unitário de P
correspondente a esse autovalor. Se você olhar de volta para a aula 7 sobre estimação de fase, vai encontrar um teorema similar
para matrizes unitárias. Lá os autovalores são números complexos no círculo unitário em vez de serem números reais não negativos,
mas caso contrário é a mesma ideia. E esses são realmente apenas dois casos especiais de um teorema mais geral conhecido como
teorema espectral. Ele não funciona para toda matriz. Você precisa que a matriz comute com sua
própria transposta conjugada, e é isso que significa uma matriz ser normal. Mas de fato sempre temos
isso tanto para matrizes unitárias quanto para matrizes positivas semidefinidas, e para matrizes hermitianas de forma mais geral, onde
sempre teremos autovalores reais, mas não necessariamente não negativos. Então essa é uma declaração do
teorema espectral apenas para matrizes positivas semidefinidas. E agora vamos ver o que ele nos diz sobre as matrizes de
densidade. O que ele nos diz é que para uma matriz de densidade N por N arbitrária, sempre podemos expressar essa matriz como uma combinação convexa
de n estados puros. E além disso, podemos escolher esses n estados puros como sendo
ortogonais. Isso decorre bastante diretamente do teorema juntamente com um fato básico da álgebra linear, que é que
a soma dos autovalores de qualquer matriz é sempre igual ao traço dessa matriz. Em outras palavras, tudo o que estamos realmente
fazendo aqui é renomear os autovalores p 0 a pN menos um e então observar que quando fazemos isso e
coletamos esses autovalores em um vetor N-dimensional, necessariamente obtemos um vetor de probabilidade porque todos têm que ser não negativos e sua soma é igual
ao traço de rho, que é um porque rho é uma matriz de densidade. Então isso é bastante simples, mas é
realmente bastante fundamental conceitualmente. O que nos diz é que toda matriz de densidade,
por mais complicada que possa parecer, poderia surgir ao primeiro selecionar uma base ortonormal de qualquer sistema
sobre o qual estamos falando e, em seguida, escolher aleatoriamente um estado quântico dessa base de acordo com alguma escolha das probabili
dades. Se não estiver imediatamente claro por que isso é interessante ou importante, tudo bem. Mas de fato usamos esse
fato com muita frequência quando estamos raciocinando sobre matrizes de densidade. E de fato, expressar uma dada matriz de densidade
dessa forma é geralmente a primeira coisa que fazemos quando queremos entendê-la
melhor. Aqui está um exemplo. Lembre a matriz de densidade que elaboramos anteriormente, onde escolhemos aleatoriamente entre
o estado zero e o estado mais, cada um com probabilidade 1/2, que como calculamos tem uma matriz de densidade que
parece com esta. O estado zero e o estado mais não são ortogonais, então essa não é uma
decomposição espectral. Mas se calcularmos uma, o que podemos fazer com um computador ou à mão em um caso como esse, então o que
obtemos é essa expressão de nossa matriz de densidade onde os autovalores são esses números que continuam aparecendo e
onde os autovetores correspondentes podem ser escolhidos como mostrado aqui embaixo na tela. E novamente, já vimos esses vetores antes, por exemplo, no
contexto do jogo CHSH na aula quatro. Então isso é interessante. De acordo com
a expressão original, esse estado é o que obtemos ao escolher uniformemente entre dois estados: o estado zero e
o estado mais. Mas de fato obtemos exatamente a mesma matriz de densidade ao escolher aleatoriamente entre dois estados
puros, mas favorecendo muito fortemente um deles, cerca de 85% para o primeiro e apenas cerca de 15% para
o segundo. Então, em certo sentido, há na verdade bem menos aleatoriedade inerente ao estado do que poderia ter
parecido inicialmente. Há uma forma geométrica muito elegante de pensar e visualizar os estados quânticos de um único qubit, conhecida
como esfera de Bloch. Ela só funciona para qubits individuais. Para sistemas com três
ou mais estados clássicos, incluindo dois ou mais qubits juntos, ela não funciona mais. Então é bastante limitada, mas
ainda assim é uma ótima forma de pensar sobre os estados de um único qubit. Ela poderia ter sido introduzida bem
lá atrás na primeira aula da série, sobre sistemas individuais, mas não é realmente essencial para entender como a informação quântica funciona. E ela também tem uma
conexão muito bonita com as matrizes de densidade, então se encaixa naturalmente nesta aula. E de fato vou explicar
isso de uma forma um pouco diferente da forma como é tipicamente explicada, usando as matrizes de densidade para efetivamente
derivá-la. Então, se você já estiver familiarizado com a esfera de Bloch, essa explicação pode ser um pouco diferente da
forma como você primeiro aprendeu sobre ela. Mas no final deveria ser equivalente, é claro. Vamos começar pensando sobre
os possíveis estados puros de um qubit, primeiro conforme representados por vetores de estado
quântico. A menos de uma fase global, todo vetor de estado quântico de qubit pode ser expresso como
mostrado aqui na tela. Para ser preciso, temos dois números reais Theta e fi, e vamos
pensar sobre esses dois números como sendo ângulos expressos em radianos. O primeiro número Theta está entre 0 e Pi, ou equivalentemente, é um
ângulo entre 0 e 180°. E o segundo número fi está entre 0 e 2 pi, incluindo 0 mas não 2
pi, ou seja, qualquer ângulo entre 0 e 360°. A entrada zero do nosso vetor é
cosseno de theta sobre 2, então é um número real entre 0 e 1 e em particular é necessariamente não negativo.
E a entrada um do nosso vetor é e elevado a i vezes fi vezes o seno de theta sobre 2. E isso pode ser
qualquer número complexo no círculo unitário complexo ou dentro dele. Esse é sempre um vetor unitário, ou
em outras palavras, é um vetor de estado quântico válido. E para qualquer dado vetor de estado quântico de qubit, sempre podemos encontrar
um vetor desta forma que é equivalente a esse vetor a menos de uma fase global. Em particular, sempre podemos
multiplicar o vetor dado por uma fase global para tornar a entrada zero um número real não negativo, escolher qualquer
Theta que nos dê essa entrada, e depois escolher fi para corresponder à entrada um. A magnitude da entrada um sempre
necessariamente concordará com o seno de theta sobre dois, pela suposição de que começamos com um vetor
unitário. Agora não é exatamente o caso que Theta e fi são unicamente determinados pelo vetor de estado quântico com que começamos,
mas é quase o caso. Sempre haverá um valor único de theta entre zero e Pi que funcione.
E geralmente há um valor único de fi que funciona, mas em dois casos especiais isso não é verdade. Em particular, se começamos com um
estado da base padrão, então Theta será zero ou pi, e em ambos os casos, na verdade, não importa o que fi é, é
completamente irrelevante. Quando Theta é zero, o cosseno de theta sobre 2 é 1 e o seno de theta sobre 2
é zero. Então estamos multiplicando e elevado a i vezes fi por zero, então não faz nenhuma diferença o que fi é.
E se Theta é pi, desta vez o cosseno é zero e o seno é um. Então temos e elevado a i vezes fi vezes ket 1, mas esses
vetores são todos equivalentes a menos de uma fase global, então novamente não importa o que fi é. No entanto, se Theta fica estritamente
entre zero e Pi, então sempre haverá um valor único de fi que funciona. E, aliás, essa possível
degenerescência no valor de fi para os dois casos especiais fará todo sentido quando virmos a imagem geométrica em
pouco tempo. Agora vamos calcular a matriz de densidade associada a um vetor de estado da forma que acabamos de
identificar. Então esse vai ser um estado puro de um qubit. Para fazer isso, multiplicamos o vetor
pela sua transposta conjugada, como de costume. E na tela está uma expressão da matriz que obtemos calculando a
transposta conjugada e fazendo a multiplicação. Agora, assim como toda matriz 2x2,
há uma forma única de obter essa matriz tomando uma combinação linear das matrizes de Pauli
incluindo a matriz identidade. Em particular, podemos obter essa matriz escolhendo os coeficientes das
matrizes de Pauli como mostrado aqui na tela. Estamos colocando um dois no denominador porque isso vai fazer
tudo funcionar bem. Nada nos obriga a fazer isso, mas podemos e vai ser útil fazê-lo. Mas além
dessa escolha cosmética, não há liberdade aqui. Esta é a única forma de obter essa matriz tomando uma combinação linear das matrizes de Pauli. Isso é
porque as matrizes de Pauli incluindo a matriz identidade são uma base para o espaço vetorial de todas as matrizes 2x2. Uma forma
de verificar a correção desta expressão é usar algumas identidades trigonométricas básicas. E em particular, se eu sair do caminho por
apenas um momento, aqui temos algumas identidades que farão o truque. Então, se você quiser, pause o vídeo ou
tire um screenshot e veja se você consegue obter a segunda expressão da matriz de densidade na parte de baixo a partir da primeira. Então, em resumo, qualquer estado puro de um
qubit expresso como uma matriz de densidade pode ser escrito como uma combinação linear das matrizes de Pauli como mostrado na
tela, para Theta entre 0 e pi e fi entre 0 e 2 pi. Note que temos precisamente a
mesma degenerescência de antes, que é que fi é irrelevante quando Theta é zero ou pi. E desta vez podemos ver
isso com mais clareza porque o seno de theta é zero nesses dois casos e, caso contrário, não é. Vale a pena notar
que nessa fórmula temos Theta aparecendo como argumento das funções seno e cosseno, em vez de Theta sobre 2 como na versão original do vetor de estado
quântico. E isso é porque usamos essas identidades trigonométricas, as primeiras três das quais são basicamente
rearranjos das chamadas fórmulas de ângulo duplo. Então o ângulo efetivamente é dobrado. E agora estamos finalmente prontos para
falar sobre a esfera de Bloch em si. Vamos focar nos três coeficientes das matrizes de Pauli não identidade
no numerador da expressão de nossa matriz de densidade. Então estamos ignorando o dois no
denominador. Também estamos ignorando a matriz identidade porque o coeficiente nessa nunca muda. Isso acontece porque esse
coeficiente é determinado pelo traço de qualquer matriz que estamos expressando, e as matrizes de densidade sempre têm traço igual
a um. Agora imagine que temos três eixos rotulados x, y e z, orientados de acordo com a
chamada regra da mão direita, e considere o ponto cujas coordenadas correspondem aos três coeficientes. E só para ser claro, esse é
o espaço tridimensional ordinário de que estamos falando, onde as coordenadas são sempre números reais. A
coordenada x corresponde ao coeficiente da matriz de Pauli sigma X no numerador de nossa expressão, que é sempre um número real porque as matrizes de
densidade são hermitianas, e da mesma forma para Y e Z. O que encontramos é que esse ponto que
obtemos está sempre na esfera unitária, ou em outras palavras, a esfera com raio igual a
um. E em particular, é o ponto que obtemos se começarmos no ponto onde o eixo z positivo cruza a esfera,
que podemos pensar como o Polo Norte, rotacionar em direção ao eixo x positivo por um ângulo de theta e, em seguida,
rotacionar em direção ao eixo y positivo, ou em outras palavras, para leste, por um ângulo de fi. Nesse contexto, o ângulo Theta é
chamado de ângulo polar, que é fácil de lembrar porque começa no polo. E fi é chamado de
ângulo azimutal. E juntos esses dois ângulos representam coordenadas esféricas para os pontos na esfera unitária. E se
você quisesse, poderia também deixar o raio variar para representar pontos arbitrários no espaço tridimensional, mas aqui estamos focando nos pontos na
esfera unitária onde o raio é igual a um. Você também pode pensar em Theta como representando latitude, exceto que vamos
de 0 a 180° do Polo Norte ao Polo Sul, em vez de mais ou menos 90° a partir do equador. E fi representa
a longitude, onde basicamente definimos o meridiano principal como sendo o meridiano que cruza o eixo x
positivo. Se você for como eu, aliás, e tiver dificuldade em lembrar qual é latitude e qual é longitude, pode ser útil lembrar
que longitude corresponde ao intervalo que é mais longo: 2 pi em vez de
Pi. Enfim, o ponto que obtemos na esfera unitária a partir do nosso vetor de estado quântico de qubit s, pensando sobre coordenadas desta
forma, é a representação na esfera de Bloch do estado quântico correspondente a psi. E quando pensamos sobre toda a
esfera unitária tridimensional desta forma, obtemos a esfera de Bloch. Geometricamente é apenas uma esfera unitária
no espaço tridimensional ordinário, mas de fato essa é a geometria dos estados de
qubit. Há uma correspondência biunívoca perfeita aqui. Todo estado puro de um qubit corresponde a um ponto único na
esfera, e todo ponto na esfera representa um estado único de qubit a menos de uma fase global. Quando estamos trabalhando com
vetores de estado quântico, essa correspondência recebe outros nomes, aliás. Às vezes também é chamada de esfera de Poincaré, por
exemplo. Mas no contexto de informação quântica, é geralmente referida como esfera de Bloch. Note que agora podemos ver a
degenerescência no ângulo fi com bastante clareza, porque longitude não tem significado nos Polos Norte e Sul. Mas além
dos polos, todo ponto na Terra tem coordenadas únicas em termos de latitude e longitude. E a mesma coisa está acontecendo aqui. Então é assim que
a esfera de Bloch funciona em geral. Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos específicos de estados de qubit e
onde eles ficam na esfera de Bloch. Vamos começar com a base padrão. Esses são os pontos que obtemos
quando o ângulo polar Theta é zero para o estado zero e Pi para o estado um. Esses são os dois casos onde o
ângulo azimutal fi é irrelevante, como já discuti. Podemos também expressar as matrizes de densidade correspondentes como combinações lineares
das matrizes de Pauli. De qualquer forma, concluímos que esses dois estados correspondem ao Polo Norte e ao
Polo Sul da esfera de Bloch. O estado zero está no topo e o estado um está na
parte inferior. A seguir, vamos encontrar os estados mais e menos na esfera de Bloch. Novamente, podemos pensar
em vetores de estado quântico ou em matrizes de densidade. Para vetores de estado quântico, desta vez o ângulo polar Theta tem que ser Pi
sobre 2 para que a entrada zero seja 1 sobre raiz de 2. O ângulo azimutal fi tem que ser zero
para o estado mais porque a entrada um é positiva para o estado mais. E tem que ser Pi ou 180° para o estado menos
porque essa entrada é negativa nesse caso. Então esses dois pontos ficam no
equador da esfera de Bloch. O estado mais é onde o eixo x positivo cruza a esfera, e o estado menos fica do lado oposto, onde o
eixo x negativo cruza a esfera. Equivalentemente, também podemos ver pelas expressões das matrizes de Pauli para as
matrizes de densidade correspondentes que as coordenadas Y e Z são ambas zero, enquanto as coordenadas x são positivas e negativas
1. Outro exemplo é a base mais i, menos i, que é similar à base mais-menos exceto que também multiplicamos a
entrada um por i, a unidade imaginária. Já vimos o estado mais i anteriormente na aula, e o estado menos i é definido
de forma análoga. O ângulo polar Theta é o mesmo que era para os estados mais e menos: pi sobre
2. E desta vez precisamos escolher o ângulo azimutal fi de modo que obtenhamos i e menos i em vez de 1 e menos 1.
E pi sobre 2 e 3 pi sobre 2 são as escolhas certas para isso. Mais uma vez, podemos também olhar para
as descrições em matriz de densidade desses estados, e as coisas são bastante similares aos dois exemplos anteriores, exceto que desta vez é a matriz de Pauli Y no lugar
de Z ou X. Então, na esfera de Bloch, esses dois estados estão localizados onde o eixo y
cruza a esfera. E se organizarmos um pouco, podemos ver com mais clareza como os seis estados que acabamos de discutir
se relacionam entre si. Para apenas mais um exemplo, ou realmente uma classe de exemplos, considere os
vetores de estado quântico de qubit que surgiram anteriormente e na aula quatro, onde a entrada zero é cosseno de alpha para algum número real Alpha e a entrada um
é o seno de alpha. Podemos, aliás, restringir nossa atenção a valores de alpha entre zero e Pi, porque qualquer
outro valor de alpha nos dará um vetor que é equivalente a menos de uma fase global a um onde Alpha está nesse
intervalo. Se calcularmos as matrizes de densidade associadas a esses estados, expressas como combinações lineares das matrizes de Pauli,
obtemos a expressão que está mostrada aqui na tela. Esse cálculo não está mostrado aqui, mas é isso que você deveria
obter se o fizer. E o que encontramos é que esses estados formam um chamado círculo máximo que passa
pelos polos. Especificamente, partindo do Polo Norte quando Alpha é zero, descendo pelo meridiano principal e
chegando ao Polo Sul quando Alpha é pi sobre 2, e depois de volta ao Polo Norte no lado oposto da esfera conforme Alpha vai de pi sobre 2 a
Pi. E isso tudo faz sentido porque, primeiro, esses são vetores reais, então a parte imaginária é sempre zero. E segundo,
o ângulo Alpha efetivamente é dobrado na esfera de Bloch. E mais uma vez, isso pode ser explicado pelo uso
das fórmulas de ângulo duplo. Vimos que a esfera de Bloch fornece uma representação geométrica muito elegante para os estados puros de um
qubit, onde cada ponto na esfera corresponde a um estado puro único de um qubit e vice-
versa. Quando nos referimos à bola de Bloch, estamos falando de todos os pontos na esfera de Bloch, bem como os pontos
contidos dentro dela. Os pontos no interior da bola de Bloch também correspondem a estados de qubit,
especificamente estados que não são estados puros. Em outras palavras, esses são estados de qubit que podem ser representados por matrizes de densidade mas não por vetores de estado de qubit.
Um aspecto fundamental da bola de Bloch e da forma como os pontos interiores representam estados impuros é que
as combinações convexas de pontos dentro da bola de Bloch correspondem a combinações convexas de matrizes de densidade.
Intuitivamente, isso significa que a geometria continua funcionando perfeitamente mesmo dentro da bola de
Bloch. Vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos, começando com o ponto central da bola de Bloch, que representa o
estado completamente misto. O estado completamente misto é obtido ao calcular a média dos estados zero e um, o que é consistente com o fato
de que o centro da esfera fica exatamente na metade do caminho entre o Polo Norte e o Polo Sul. E de fato, fica na metade do caminho entre quaisquer dois pontos antipodais, como
os estados mais e menos, e os estados mais i e menos i. Os pontos antipodais na esfera de Bloch sempre correspondem a
estados puros ortogonais. E o que isso revela ou reflete é que sempre podemos escrever o estado completamente misto
como a média entre quaisquer dois estados puros de qubit ortogonais. Outra forma de ver isso é
pensar sobre a representação em matrizes de Pauli do estado completamente misto. Para fazer isso funcionar, temos que definir
os coeficientes em todas as três matrizes de Pauli não identidade como zero. Então o ponto correspondente dentro da
bola de Bloch fica bem no centro, na origem. E, aliás, pensar sobre as representações em matrizes de Pauli das matrizes de
densidade assim torna bastante claro que as combinações convexas de pontos da bola de Bloch correspondem a combinações convexas
de matrizes de densidade. Se tomarmos uma média ou uma média ponderada de matrizes de densidade e
expressarmos tudo em termos de combinações lineares das matrizes de Pauli, então claro que estamos apenas calculando a média dos pontos correspondentes porque tudo
é linear nesses três coeficientes. Para mais um exemplo, vamos considerar a média do estado zero
e do estado mais, que vimos anteriormente na aula. Calculamos a representação em matriz de densidade que está mostrada na
tela, e temos que o ponto está no interior da bola de Bloch, na metade do caminho entre os estados zero e mais.
Também vimos que poderíamos expressar essa matriz de densidade de uma forma diferente com base em sua decomposição espectral. E
novamente, isso é consistente com o diagrama e os exemplos anteriores. E isso conclui a
discussão da esfera de Bloch e da bola de Bloch. As pessoas frequentemente perguntam se há uma esfera de Bloch ou bola de Bloch para sistemas com
três ou mais estados clássicos. E a resposta infeliz é: não exatamente. Podemos sempre pensar sobre os
estados quânticos de um sistema em termos geométricos similares à bola de Bloch e obteremos um corpo convexo em um espaço vetorial real.
Mas se tivermos três ou mais estados clássicos, não será esférico. Por exemplo, se tivermos
exatamente três estados clássicos, ou um qutrit resumindo, obteremos um corpo convexo em um espaço de oito dimensões.
Mas os pontos extremos desse corpo, que correspondem aos estados quânticos puros de um qutrit, serão apenas
quadridimensionais. Se você consegue visualizar uma variedade quadridimensional num espaço de oito dimensões e de alguma forma envolvê-la para obter um corpo convexo
e isso te parece uma forma útil de pensar sobre qutrits, então ótimo para você, suponho. É interessante
pensar sobre, mas não é uma bola, é mais complicado do que isso. Na parte final da aula, vamos discutir brevemente
como as matrizes de densidade funcionam para múltiplos sistemas. As matrizes de densidade podem representar estados de múltiplos sistemas, e isso
funciona de forma completamente análoga aos vetores de estado quântico. Em particular, assim como temos na formulação simplificada da informação
quântica, podemos visualizar múltiplos sistemas juntos como se fossem um único sistema
composto. Desta vez, tanto as linhas quanto as colunas das matrizes de densidade que representam estados de múltiplos sistemas são
colocadas em correspondência com o produto cartesiano dos conjuntos de estados clássicos dos sistemas individuais. Por exemplo, podemos considerar
representações em matrizes de densidade dos quatro estados de Bell, que obtemos precisamente como fizemos para outros vetores de estado
quântico anteriormente na aula, multiplicando vetores de estado pelas suas transpostas conjugadas. E os resultados são mostrados aqui na
tela. Em essência, não há nada de novo em nível conceitual, embora veremos em breve que há algumas
coisas novas que podemos fazer com matrizes de densidade para múltiplos sistemas. As noções de independência e
correlações se transferem dos vetores de estado quântico para as matrizes de densidade. E em particular, encontramos que os produtos tensoriais
de matrizes de densidade representam independência entre sistemas. Usamos a mesma terminologia que
usamos para vetores de estado quântico. Por exemplo, se temos um sistema X que está preparado em um estado rho e um sistema Y
que está independentemente preparado em um estado sigma, então o estado do par XY juntos é dado pelo produto tensorial
de rho e sigma. Chamamos isso de estado produto, e isso se generaliza de forma natural para mais de dois
sistemas. Matrizes de densidade que não podem ser expressas como estados produto representam correlações entre sistemas. E essa
parte é similar aos vetores de estado quântico, mas há diferentes tipos de correlações que podem surgir quando usamos matrizes de densidade, mesmo para
apenas dois sistemas. Em contraste, há realmente apenas um tipo de correlação que podemos ter para vetores de estado quântico. E
esse tipo é o entrelaçamento. Para dizer isso de outra forma, correlação e entrelaçamento são sinônimos para vetores de estado quântico, mas
isso não é verdade para matrizes de densidade. Aqui as coisas são mais interessantes. Por exemplo, podemos descrever
estados clássicos correlacionados com matrizes de densidade. Aqui está um exemplo de uma matriz de densidade representando um bit aleatório clássico
compartilhado entre Alice e Bob. Eles sempre têm o mesmo estado clássico, zero ou um, e a probabilidade é
1/2 para cada uma das possibilidades. Isso não é um estado entrelaçado. Entrelaçamento é não clássico, mas
é um estado correlacionado. Outro exemplo está conectado com a noção de um ensemble de estados quânticos,
que você pode pensar como uma distribuição de probabilidade sobre um conjunto finito de estados quânticos. Em particular, vamos imaginar que
temos M matrizes de densidade rho zero a rho M menos um, todas representando possíveis estados de um sistema específico,
juntamente com uma probabilidade para obter cada uma. Se quiséssemos, poderíamos calcular a média ponderada dessas matrizes de densidade
tomando uma combinação convexa delas, mas isso na verdade não nos diria quais são os estados individuais ou quais
são as probabilidades. O que podemos fazer em vez disso, e às vezes é bastante útil fazer isso, é considerar uma matriz de
densidade da forma mostrada aqui na tela. Esse é um estado de dois sistemas onde o primeiro sistema tem um estado clássico
para cada uma das alternativas e tomamos a média ponderada de M estados produto onde o estado do
primeiro sistema é sempre clássico e essencialmente rotula qual dos m estados temos para o segundo
sistema. Se não estiver claro exatamente por que queremos pensar sobre estados como esse, tudo bem. É apenas um exemplo de
um tipo de correlação onde o primeiro sistema é sempre clássico e o segundo sistema pode estar em um estado
quântico. Uma terceira categoria de estados possivelmente correlacionados é o conjunto dos chamados estados
separáveis. Em termos simples, esses são combinações convexas de estados produto e essencialmente representam estados
quânticos onde quaisquer correlações entre os sistemas são correlações clássicas. Uma forma de pensar sobre
estados como esse é que fazemos uma seleção probabilística para um número K e então independentemente preparamos dois
sistemas em um estado quântico que pode depender dessa escolha de K. O que é talvez mais interessante sobre
estados desta forma é que é assim que de fato definimos o entrelaçamento em termos matemáticos. Em particular, o entrelaçamento é
definido como uma falta de separabilidade. Então, se você tem uma matriz de densidade e não é possível expressá-la numa forma
como essa, então por definição ela é entrelaçada. Aludi a isso de volta na aula quatro e aqui está em um pouco
mais de detalhe. Aliás, pode ser muito difícil descobrir se uma dada matriz de densidade representa um estado entrelaçado,
mesmo com a ajuda de um computador. Matemática e computacionalmente falando, o entrelaçamento é
na verdade bastante complicado. Mencionei no início da aula que há uma coisa muito importante que podemos fazer com as matrizes de densidade,
que é descrever os estados de partes isoladas de sistemas, mesmo quando estão correlacionadas e possivelmente entrelaçadas com outros
sistemas. O termo estado reduzido é frequentemente usado neste contexto. E como um exemplo simples, vamos calcular os estados reduzidos
para os qubits individuais que formam um ebit. Para ser preciso, vamos supor que
Alice e Bob compartilham um ebit. Alice possui um qubit A, Bob possui um qubit B, e juntos esses dois qubits estão em um estado phi
mais. E a pergunta que vamos abordar é: qual é o estado do qubit A de Alice em
isolamento? Claro que poderíamos fazer a mesma pergunta para o qubit de Bob, mas é fácil responder a essa pergunta uma vez que sabemos a resposta a esta.
Agora pode ser tentador dizer que não podemos descrever o estado do qubit de Alice em isolamento porque ele está
entrelaçado com o qubit de Bob, o que poderia de alguma forma nos proibir de descrever ou mesmo pensar sobre o estado de A em
isolamento. Mas isso é falso. É verdade que não podemos descrever o estado de A com um vetor de estado
quântico, porque como veremos, ele não está num estado puro. Mas todo sistema tem um estado em qualquer dado momento que pode ser
descrito por uma matriz de densidade, esteja ele entrelaçado com outro sistema ou não. Como experimento mental, apenas para nos ajudar
a ver qual é a resposta para essa pergunta, vamos supor que Bob decide pegar seu qubit e viajar para as estrelas, e nunca mais se tem notícias dele.
Mas imagine que em algum momento do caminho ele decide realizar uma medição na base padrão no seu
qubit. Bem, sabemos como calcular as probabilidades para ele obter os dois possíveis resultados, e também sabemos qual será
o estado de A para cada resultado possível. E essas coisas estão resumidas nessa tabela. Em particular, com probabilidade 1/2,
A ficará no estado zero, e com probabilidade 1/2, A ficará no estado um. Então, como foi discutido anteriormente na
aula, isso deixa A no estado completamente misto. E portanto, essa é a resposta
para nossa pergunta. Agora você pode objetar e dizer que isso depende do fato de que
Bob decidiu medir seu qubit, e a suposição de que ele faz isso faz parte da história que nos levou a essa resposta. Mas
se Bob está a anos-luz de distância quando mede, nada que ele faça poderia possivelmente ter qualquer influência em qualquer
experimento que Alice possa decidir realizar em seu qubit. Caso contrário, teríamos comunicação mais rápida que a
luz. Então o qubit de Alice está no estado completamente misto independentemente de Bob
medir ou não. Devo deixar claro neste ponto que a noção de estado reduzido e a forma como eles são definidos não tem realmente nenhuma dependência da relatividade
ou da impossibilidade de comunicação mais rápida que a luz. Isso é apenas uma forma de explicá-lo em termos esperançosamente intuitivos.
Na realidade, há uma definição matemática que veremos em um contexto mais geral em alguns momentos. Ela é consistente com essa resposta
e coincidentemente com a impossibilidade de comunicação mais rápida que a luz. E também não há nenhuma outra
definição que poderia ser consistente com a informação quântica como a conhecemos. Agora vamos considerar os estados reduzidos em maior
generalidade. Suponha que temos um par de sistemas A e B, não necessariamente qubits, que estão juntos em um estado puro
representado por um vetor de estado quântico s. Novamente, vamos focar no estado reduzido do sistema A, e para fazer
isso vai ser útil pensar sobre os estados clássicos do sistema B. Então seja gamma esse conjunto de
estados clássicos de B. Como discutimos antes, de volta à aula dois da série, por exemplo,
há uma coleção única de vetores phi b para cada B em Gamma para os quais a expressão de s mostrada na tela
é correta. E em particular, há uma fórmula simples para esses vetores. Simplesmente multiplicamos o vetor s pelo
produto tensorial da matriz identidade correspondente ao sistema A com bra B para qualquer B em que estejamos interessados.
O que estamos fazendo aqui é basicamente nos preparando para calcular o que aconteceria se fôssemos realizar uma
medição na base padrão em B. E novamente, isso foi coberto na aula dois da
série. Então, suponha que realizamos uma medição na base padrão em B. Cada resultado possível apareceria
com probabilidade igual à norma euclidiana ao quadrado do vetor phi b correspondente. E condicionado a obter um
resultado específico b, normalizamos o vetor phi b para determinar o estado resultante de
A. Seguindo o mesmo raciocínio que no exemplo do ebit de alguns momentos atrás, obtemos a expressão mostrada na
tela para o estado reduzido de A como uma matriz de densidade. E, aliás, a norma ao quadrado no denominador vem de
multiplicar o vetor normalizado pela sua transposta conjugada, então pegamos a norma euclidiana duas vezes no
denominador. As normas euclidianas ao quadrado se cancelam e ficamos com uma expressão bastante simples.
E de fato, se substituirmos nossa fórmula para phi b, que funciona para todo B, obtemos uma fórmula para o estado reduzido
do sistema A em termos da descrição em matriz de densidade do estado puro com que começamos, ou seja, ket psi bra
psi. Então essa é nossa fórmula para o estado reduzido do sistema A, supondo que o sistema composto AB começou no
estado puro psi. Mas também podemos usar a fórmula de forma mais geral. Em particular, vamos supor
que o estado de AB é dado por alguma matriz de densidade rho, que poderia ter a forma ket psi bra psi para algum vetor de estado
quântico s, mas não necessariamente. Segue-se basicamente por linearidade que o estado reduzido de A é
determinado pela mesma fórmula que tínhamos para estados puros, exceto que substituímos qualquer matriz de densidade rho que
desejarmos. Como notação abreviada, é bastante comum que denotemos esse estado reduzido pelo nome que estamos usando para a
matriz de densidade rho neste caso, mas colocamos um subscrito indicando o sistema no qual estamos focando. Então rho com
um subscrito A significa o estado reduzido de A quando o sistema composto está no estado rho. Superescritos também são às vezes usados
no lugar de subscritos. É basicamente apenas uma preferência pessoal e significa a mesma
coisa. Temos nos focado no sistema A apenas por simplicidade, mas também podemos obter o estado reduzido do sistema B
de forma análoga, mas onde a fórmula é adaptada da forma natural. Tudo é simétrico aqui. Estamos
essencialmente apenas trocando os papéis de A e B. E em particular, a soma vai sobre os estados clássicos de A desta vez,
em vez de B. E na fórmula na tela, estamos assumindo que o conjunto de estados clássicos de A é chamado de
Sigma. Tudo isso se generaliza de forma bastante direta para três ou mais sistemas. Por exemplo, se tivermos três
sistemas A, B e C que estão coletivamente no estado descrito pela matriz de densidade rho, então podemos obter o
estado reduzido do par A junto com B pela fórmula mostrada aqui, bem como o estado do terceiro sistema sozinho,
que é a segunda fórmula. E você pode considerar outras combinações e generalizar isso para quantos sistemas quiser. As somas são sempre tomadas sobre
os conjuntos de estados clássicos dos sistemas que estão sendo ignorados, e o padrão é sempre o mesmo, com a matriz de
densidade com que começamos sendo encaixada entre o produto tensorial da matriz identidade e bras e kets correspondentes a estados da
base padrão. Para concluir a aula, vou dizer apenas um pouco mais sobre as definições que acabamos de cobrir. A operação sobre matrizes de densidade
que descreve os estados reduzidos tem um nome e é chamada de traço parcial. Para dois sistemas A e B, o
traço parcial sobre B e o traço parcial sobre A são como definidos aqui na tela. Essas são exatamente as mesmas
fórmulas que vimos alguns momentos atrás. E agora estamos apenas pensando nelas como funções de rho e dando-lhes
nomes. Os nomes parecem com o traço, exceto que há um subscrito que nos diz qual sistema está sendo removido,
ou em outras palavras, qual sistema é aquele cujo conjunto de estados clássicos estamos somando e que está sendo encaixado entre um bra e um
ket. Quando tomamos o traço parcial de rho sobre B, por exemplo, descrito pela primeira fórmula, às vezes dizemos que
B é "traçado fora" e da mesma forma para A. Intuitivamente falando, traçar fora um
sistema apenas significa que o jogamos fora ou simplesmente o ignoramos. Essa é uma forma de definir o traço
parcial. E outra forma equivalente é dizer que esses mapeamentos são os únicos mapeamentos lineares que satisfazem as
fórmulas mostradas aqui à direita. Especificamente, se tivermos um produto tensorial de duas matrizes M e N, digamos,
e realizarmos o traço parcial sobre o primeiro sistema, então o que obtemos é o traço da primeira matriz M vezes
a segunda matriz. E a condição é simétrica quando traçamos sobre o segundo sistema. Nem toda matriz para a qual calcularíamos
o traço parcial é um produto tensorial como esse, mas toda matriz pode ser expressa como uma combinação linear de
produtos tensoriais, e podemos determinar o traço parcial a partir dessas condições juntamente com o fato de que essas são funções
lineares. E é por isso que é chamado de traço parcial. Essa definição equivalente pode ser
bastante útil porque muitas vezes podemos usá-la em vez da fórmula original. Aqui está um exemplo que
ilustra isso. Suponha que temos um par de qubits A e B no estado cuja matriz de densidade é mostrada aqui na
tela. Esse é um exemplo de um estado correlacionado onde A está no estado zero ou no estado um, cada um
com probabilidade 1/2. Então podemos pensar em A como sendo clássico. Se A está no estado zero, então
B também está. E se A está no estado um, então B está no estado mais. Se queremos saber qual é o estado reduzido de A,
traçamos B. E se usarmos a segunda fórmula da definição equivalente juntamente com linearidade, então podemos
calcular isso bem facilmente. Em particular, o traço de ket 0 bra 0 é um, assim como o traço de ket mais bra
mais. Então esses fatores tensoriais desaparecem e ficamos com o estado completamente misto. De forma similar, podemos calcular
o estado reduzido de B traçando A. Desta vez é o primeiro fator tensorial que estamos realizando o traço. Então
estamos usando a primeira fórmula da definição equivalente e ficamos com 1/2 vezes ket 0 bra 0 mais 1/2 vezes ket
mais bra mais, ou em outras palavras, a mesma matriz de densidade que surgiu algumas vezes anteriormente. Você obteria exatamente os mesmos
resultados se usasse as fórmulas da primeira definição, mas esse é um jeito muito mais fácil de fazer. Tudo isso se generaliza para três ou mais
sistemas, mas para este vídeo vou parar aqui e deixar isso para você considerar por conta própria. E isso é tudo para esta aula, que
introduziu as matrizes de densidade e descreveu os fundamentos de como elas funcionam. Também discutimos a esfera de Bloch
bem como os diferentes tipos de correlações e a noção de estado reduzido de um sistema. Espero que você se junte a mim para a
próxima aula, que é sobre canais, que são mapeamentos lineares de matrizes de densidade para matrizes de densidade que
descrevem operações em sistemas. Até
a próxima.